Wow nice suit definite Stanley oh Jesus
oh that's not good no no no oh you're
not going to walk that one off oh that's
a grouse oh hey everybody huge news we
got a Deadpool TV series we got to talk
about in a whole bunch of new mutant
stuff so I'll explain what's up no joke
there is a Deadpool TV series the FXX is
producing it's going to drop in 2018
I'll explain some of the details
everyone's asking what's it going to be
rated what's it going to look like but
they also just confirms that Maisie
Williams joined the New Mutants movie as
Wolfsbane and anya taylor joy is going
to be magic so there's a whole bunch of
new mutants I also have an animatic
teaser I'll play that after I talk about
the Deadpool stuff but just because this
is so awesome new round of the Marvel
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video it's for guardians to tickets so
the big deal with the Deadpool TV series
of course Deadpool is blowing up they
would try to make as many things as
possible but Ryan Reynolds is only one
man he could only make so many movies
he's already going to be in the x-force
movie they're working on they have new
mutants there's this big Deadpool
universe that is probably going to blow
all of the x-men movies away Deadpool by
itself just from a box-office
perspective has blown most of the x-men
movies away already so what they've
confirmed is that they're going to be a
10 episode series it's going to be
animated and it's going to be an adult
cartoon on FXX if you don't know what
sxx is it's just a more hardcore
spin-off of the FX network so because
it's animated that means that they'll be
able to do pretty much any character
that they want to do there won't be any
problems it's not like the Deadpool
movies where there's a bunch of money
involved when they try to do x-men
characters so if there's anybody that
you've ever wanted to see on screen with
Deadpool they can do that in the TV
series Donald Glover is going to be one
of the producers there's this picture of
Rob Liefeld that he posted recently
where he said it's about time I never
thought they were going to announce this
TV series making it sound like it's been
in the works since the deadpool movie
blew up last year so they didn't say
exactly when it's going to premiere they
just said 2018 I'm going to assume for
now that it's going to be late in 2018
it'll be sometime in the fall so we
don't know what day it's going to air on
if we don't know where it's going to air
internationally so if you live outside
of the US we don't know exactly where
you'll be able to watch it which channel
it'll be on but we'll probably get most
of that information later this year
hopefully by Comic Con they'll have some
animatics to show up it takes a long
time to do animation but honestly I feel
like this is the best possible scenario
if they were to try to do a live-action
Deadpool TV series it'd be so much
harder the rules are so much bigger
about what characters they can do for
live-action and if you're big fans of
Rick and Morty they can be as hardcore
as Rick and Morty is they haven't said
who is going to be voicing Deadpool the
first thing I heard everybody asking me
on Twitter was will nolan north be the
voice of deadpool if it's going to be an
animated series there was that funny
scene from the Deadpool game where he
voiced the character Deadpool throughout
the entire game but in the game he
called himself as nolan north voicing
both of the roles know it hey what's up
buddy
we're making a game about me you got to
have you do the video you see here's the
thing people tell me we sound alike
that's how awesome Deadpool aside a
different take on maybe we just make you
you know maybe it's an alternative type
of Deadpool you know it's not yeah well
[ __ ] you know it so you can start your
petition now but I'm sure they've
already been reaching out to people
they've probably been working on the
series for a long time if they waited
this long to announce it so they
probably already know who's going to be
doing it or who their top picks are
they'll probably announce that later at
Comic Con that feels like a big Comic
Con announcement like here here's our
big Deadpool series that's coming next
year and here's who's going to be
voicing it in the really cool thing
about animated series when they come to
comic-con is that they can have the cast
read lines with animatic so you get like
a preview of what it looks like even if
the animation isn't completely ready but
before I talk about all the new mutant
stuff and play that teaser just let me
know what do you guys think about the
idea of a really hardcore Deadpool
animated series I feel like that's
probably the best case scenario that
could have happened if they're going to
do more Deadpool on TV that would be the
way to do it but if you're worried that
it's going to be watered down it's not
going to be a kids cartoon and it's not
going to be on Disney XD so if you don't
like the version that they've done on
spider-man it's not going to be anything
like that so don't worry but the really
big deal
New Mutants while I was making this
Deadpool video they confirmed that
Maisie Williams is going to be playing
Wolfsbane we kind of thought that was
going to happen last year they finally
confirmed it in anya taylor joy was
confirmed as magic so i'm super excited
about both of them magic is going to be
badass and Maisie Williams will just get
to be crazy a lot of you have asked now
that we have a Dark Phoenix movie that's
coming from the main x-men movies next
year will that mean that sophie turner
in maislin williams will get to reunite
on screen in just the way they're
pitching it the new mutants movie feels
like it'll have more in common with the
Deadpool movies that are being made like
x-force than with the main x-men film
but anything is possible I think they're
going to make the new mutants movie see
how it does and then allow it to connect
with the other movies like it's Fox
trying something new in weird that they
haven't done before like my dude with
Deadpool since Deadpool blew up now
they're letting it connect to all these
other big things there spinning out this
big x-force universe the same thing will
probably happen with new mutants but
you'll probably hear more about them
filming at this summer because they're
ramping up right now as we speak but
here's that new mutants animatic teaser
is basically the new mutants themselves
going up against demon bear who's one of
their big main villains from the comics
who's probably going to be the main
villain for the movie so there's no
dialogue this is just music underneath
this
[Music]
you
so that's just an animatic teaser you'll
probably see the first real teaser when
we get to comic-con because they'll have
been shooting for a little while so if
they want to they will have new footage
to show up but the other members of the
team that they still haven't announced
yet they're still looking for our moon
star sunspot in cannonball
so they'll fill out the five person team
obviously you know Maisie Williams from
Game of Thrones but Anya Taylor joy was
the main actress from the split movie
that just came out so if you want to see
something with her that's really cool go
see split country to cover one okay I
have the window in my room baby ditch
that's here now it closed not a token
ninja really enough oh you could leave
of all of them she is probably the one
I'm most excited about just because
magic has the coolest power she also has
a lot of the coolest costumes in the
comics so there's that too but as the
name implies she has magical abilities
she can teleport through dimensions she
has mystical armor that she can summon
and she has her soul sword so it'll be
fun to see how the movie displays all
those powers on-screen but I think
they're going to have a little bit more
fun with this group than you would see
in a traditional x-men film so expected
to move a little bit quicker like the
Deadpool movie did I think they're
building a lot on the success of
Deadpool in the way they did that story
so I think it's going to be a lot of fun
but let me know what do you guys think
about all this new mutant stuff and
leave all your requests for Deadpool or
new moons or x-men related videos in the
comments below there is an x-men gifted
TV show that's a separate thing that's
said in the x-men universe they just
drop some footage so I'll do a new video
for that in the next day or two I'll try
to get that out as fast as possible but
while you wait for that click here for a
brand new spider-man homecoming trailer
and you can click here to rewatch that
Deadpool trailer thank you so much for
watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys tonight
you